For this lesson, we're going to try our hand at adding rational expressions.
We're going to draw upon our knowledge of adding fractions to figure that out.
For example, if we wanted to add 3 11ths to 2 11ths, we would just add the
numerators and keep the denominators the same. We would get a total of 5 11ths.
Keep in mind we can only add or subtract two fractions whenever the denominators
are like. Keeping this in mind, I want you to try and add these rational
expressions together. This last one isn't addition though, it's subtraction. So
you want to make sure you subtract the numerator. You'll also need to use your
knowledge of simplifying rational expressions for these two problems. Try your
best, and don't worry if they're not right on the first try.